we can see the slides if you press the
share button
excellent
uh i think your mute admits you yeah
sorry and now can you hear me we can
hear you can you try turning off your
camera
just in case uh the bandwidth is limited
no no uh actually perfect
take it away then
okay so thank you sorry for uh the
computer program and i will start by
thanking only uh
mark and jung for the invitation and
people involved in the organization
so today i will talk about uh munitions
and reinforcement learning
uh name uh uh from the bahrain chosen
uh and the picture is from the
barometrism and
i will talk about uh similar things
so the thing is that bootstrapping
values is very it's really something
which is ubiquitous in reinforcement
learning
and uh here is how one can derive
uh or explain qrn if you knew the
optimal q function
you could regress it by uh updating a
estimate like this that is you you
target the optimal q function but you
don't know it and would you know it you
would not have to compute it
so the idea is that if you know the
optimal q function in the next state you
could do
backward induction and say that you
would
try to regress what gamma's the max of q
value
in the next state but you don't know the
q value in the next state so you place
this guy by an estimate and this is how
q learning works
and this is really ubiquitous in
reinforcement learning in the sense then
uh it used bellman so it used td and if
you choose td it
was bootstrapping but what will
bootstrap is the value in reinforcement
learning and
the idea is that maybe there are other
quantities that we could bootstrap
and there's one natural quantity
is a policy and the core idea of
this work of mutual reinforcement
learning of one week also
is to just add the log policy
to the reward and that's it and why why
doing so
interesting assume that you know the
optimal policy and uh
pick a deterministic one the log optimal
policy will be zero if the
action is optimal and it would be minus
infinity if it's sub-optimal
so this is a very strong learning signal
if you have this you have solved the
problem
but we don't know the optimal policy so
we just use the current estimate of the
policy
so the idea is to admin the reward with
the scale lock policy
which requires stochastic policy but we
will deal with this
and if this is different from maximum
maximum entropy or reinforcement
learning
because it will subtract the log policy
and not
add it and this as i said before it's
named as reference to
powerman chosen so
as a case study we'll see how to modify
the
classic dq algorithm to take into
account
this uh mutual symptom so
uh i guess that everybody knows
how they can work and what we do will
just modify the regression target of
diction
so if you look at the first equation
here it's the regulation target
it's the reward plus gamma the
expectation of
action given the current policy of the q
value and the current policy is greedy
according to the target network so
basically it's max
over action of qta but a maximum is an
expectation according to the greedy
policy
no we need a stochastic policy to use
them in chosen id so
to get them stochatic policy is a simple
way
the simpler way maybe is just to add
some entropy regularization that will
say i want to maximize the reward but i
want to have
a high enough local entropy for my
policy
if you do it properly you end up with
this
update for soft degree and
here you have the policy you know it's a
soft max over the q value
up to some temperature too and you
just have to modify removing the
lock policy uh to the q value
for those who know soft actor critic
uh it's the same algorithm except that
you don't have to actually make the the
greatest step
in discrete action setting and once
we have done this we just add the
moonshot
term that is we add the to the what we
are we had uh the
policy of the current state
and action and pay attention to the fact
that here we have menace and the area of
plus
so it's not just uh doing entropy
regularization it's more than that
and that's it uh we have a new algorithm
by just
adding two things into the regression
target so the question
is how does it work and it works pretty
well so here you see the results on the
atari game we use dopamine to
modify uh you use from dopamine
and susceptible shadow that is with
sticky actions and so on
and in orange you have dqm and in blue
you have mentioned the qn
and this core on human normalized score
mean and median average over um
or median over the 60 game of the
academic
environment and as baseline we also have
uh
c51 c51 is a distributional
algorithm reinforcement learning becomes
the first one
and a strong baseline for a
reinforcement learning agent that
don't that are not based on a
distribution on our error
and we know that i mean chosen the queen
can do better than c51
even if it doesn't use the
distributional id and even if it's
simply a simple modification of dqm
uh if we look at the program improvement
what we can see i don't know if it's
really really
the games where it doesn't works well uh
are
hard exploration as fast forward game
like montezuma or ranger or private a
and the thing is that you bootstrap your
policy that is
you will add some bonus for action you
think
are good and if you don't get a reward
you don't have a
signal to reinforce so you will
reinforce the noise of the
initialization basically
so this is not well designed for a hard
exploration game with a sparse reward
but for the over games it helps
quite a lot and as an example of the
generality of this approach we also
modified iqr so implicit content network
is a more recent
and very efficient distribution
reinforcement learning algorithm
and we did exactly the same you just add
some entropy and then you have to
mention some term and you get an
algorithm
and we see that uh it works well we have
a clear improvement over iql
and the green curve is rainbow the
rainbow from the farming
so not all the components but still um
which is an icon works uh better than
rainbow with only
the main chosen term no prioritizing
experience shortly
so the question is why does it work and
there are
two main reasons the first reason is
that it performs implicit
uh quebec labour regularization so
callback
library regularization is good it comes
with very strong performance guarantees
but
this performance guarantees relies
evenly on the fact that you
don't do errors in the greatest step and
we avoid
it with this approach and the second
aspect is that it increases the action
gap
the action gap is the distance between
the difference between the
q value of the best action and over
q values and the bigger it is uh
the less you might suffer from
estimation error
and indeed mutual generalizes advantage
learning
and you can also quantify analytically
the increase
of this action gap
so first about the regularization aspect
here you have an abstraction of
menstrual reinforcement learning if you
just take the
black part of the
if you just take the black part of the
of the equation
what you got is a dq
you compute the gradient policy right
there and then
you update the q function and the target
is what plus gamma's the expectation of
a new state of the max of occupied
then with the blue part you add the
entropy organization
and with the red parts you add some
moonshot term
and the first part the greatest step
uh the solution of this is just a convex
project gate of the entropy the solution
of this
is the softmax over true values and it
can be computed analytically given
discrete actions even with neural
networks
and the error term here is mainly the
difference between what you will do
in the ideal case and what you do
practically
now if we look at what is scalar
regularization in reinforcement learning
you can frame it like this so you take a
value iteration scheme you penalize the
greediness of the policy by a good black
liberator between the policy and the
previous one
and you add some entropy to get uh
stochastic enough policies you modify
uh the evaluation step accordingly
and this is quite uh general because you
if you put alpha to zero to zero you
will get uh entropy realization if it's
paid but alpha to one
you will get a quebec library
organization so something which is very
reminiscent of algorithm like
trpo or mpo and
you can combine both and the solution to
this grid step can be computed
analytically
and the new policy will be proportional
to the
previous one with an exponent alpha time
exponential of qk over 2
so you can compute analytically this but
you cannot
compute it analytically if you only use
neural networks because
if you look at this uh you can
you can use an induction agreement so pi
k will be proportional to exponential q
minus one
so this old guy if you take alpha equal
to 1 will be proportional it will be a
soft max
according to the sum of all pathq
functions
so you can do this in a lazy way with a
linear parametrization but
when you use neural networks you have to
remember or basket function if you want
to do this analytically and it's not
convenient
so the classic approach here is to have
an actor in addition to the critics so
you you parameterize
the policy with a neural network
and you solve approximately for the
greedy step
uh by uh doing a gradient uh decent
or gradient accent here but you lose the
nice properties because
you put if you use neural network you
have some additional error term
here and the thing is that
both schemes are indeed equivalent uh by
just writing
a rule parametrization of the q function
so the q point k
here is equal to care here minus the
block
by so the schemes are equivalent so the
bonds we have for this one
apply to this one and the bond is the
following
so here i just give a superman number
one
which doesn't really make sense in a
deep learning setting but which is easy
to read and
you have the marginal component white
spawn in the paper
but what you bound is the distance
between the optimal q function and the q
function of the policy which is the
objective outputted by his algorithm
here you have
uh one over one means gamma is the
average or reason
the average optimization or reason of
the mdp so here you have a square
dependency to this origin
and if you look at the bond formula you
only have a
mean a linear dependency to the origin
and this is much much better and very
few
uh reinforcement learning algorithm
enjoy only a linear
dependency to the reason and even fewer
that are
practical here you have the
error term and in dkn
what you pay for is a roughly a moving
average
of the norm of the errors so even if
your errors are zero mean
bounded this scheme cannot converge the
only way to have the scheme converging
is to have
the norm of the error going to zero fast
enough when you look at the bound
the error term the bond formations and
decreeing
what you have is that you have the norm
of the mean
of the error and the absolute value and
the
some are not commutative operator
here this means that if your errors are
zero mean and
bounded then this guy will go to zero
and you will have convergence
and the last term is the convergence
rate in the sense that it gives the
conversion straight where you do no
error
and it's faster for dq and then for mean
chosen
uh but it makes sense because you add
some
entropy regardless okay back level
regularization so you ask
for the algorithm to be more
conservative
but when you look this is a illustrative
example a numerical example of the bond
where we have a problem with a tabular
representation which means
that you don't you can't represent
exactly the
function but the error comes from
something and when you
zero comes from something you have a
difference
so you you will have a concentration of
zeros
and in blue you see approximately
iteration
it doesn't work it doesn't converge it
cannot converge and when you do
menstruation or equivalent caliber
organization
uh it converges a different value for
different value
of the different curves for the
different value of the temperatures
and the last thing is a increase of the
action gap so here i recall the
mean chosen updates and so we add the
log policy but the policies of soft max
of a q value so we have we can compute
this
analytically and see what it gives as a
function of the q value
so it's the q value minus the log sum x
of the q value and this log sum x is
a smooth maximum and when you take the
temperature going to zero
what you get is that you get advantage
learning and
advantage learning is an algorithm
introduced by mark
and kudis uh inspired by um
the nice thing about this algorithm is
that it increases
the action gap
but in previous work the increase was
not quantified
and the good thing is that we've been
chosen we can quantify the increase of
the action gap
and so the action gap i said before uh
is the difference between the maximum
for instance the maximum q value and the
q value of
our actions and basically you will
increase
the action guide by a ratio one plus
alpha
over one minus alpha and the propagation
of error bonds
uh are better if alpha is close to one
this bound is also better if this this
quantity is better if alpha is close to
one but
in the limit the action gap could be
infinite
uh which is uh normal
but an infinite average gap means that
you will have to
estimate the unbounded function uh and
it's not desirable so
the good thing is to take an action gap
close to 13.9
so i think that i'm running a bit out of
time so i will
skip the ablation studio so
just we have an ablation study that
shows that compares
menstrualization to advanced running
degree and software and so on
and this is baseline this is mainly an
aggregation of the results i've shown
before
so to finish with uh
menstrualism reinforcement learning is a
quite simple idea
just say add the log policy to the
reward uh
you can uh get it by uh modifying uh
existing agent and and
the modification in decline is really a
matter of
not even a number of lines but a number
of characters
it's theoretically grounded in the sense
that it performs implicit
characterization
and you have a strong performance bond
and the the interesting thing i think
is that this approach is really
interesting because we work with neural
network with a linear parametrization
you can just
do a putback level organization in the
standard way it will
it will it will work the same way it is
really interesting
thanks to the use of neural networks
and it also increase the action gap uh
with a
theoretical quantification uh an
asymptotic one without error but still
it's quantified
and it works very well because um
if you add this to icon uh it's better
than a rainbow
so if you want to know more you can
check the paper for the algorithm
the previous paper for the analysis and
both should be presented at the rips
and if you want to prepare it the card
is
open sourced under the google data
thank you
thank you so much matu this is fantastic
um
well let's open up the floor to
questions we have about 10 minutes
uh well i guess i can ask a question i
mean i also really love this circus uh
seems like today's that kind of day
so uh i'm just i'm just like really
wondering
like if these error terms that you have
in the bound
showing up do they really have the same
meaning as before because now you're
trying to estimate
sort of a different loss function that
is not just rewards but also
these k are divergences and maybe
they're on a different scale and maybe
that you're adding
like larger errors together yes you're
right
um but by increasing the action gap you
will increase
the range of the function you try to
estimate and in the limit
you know that the the range the function
you're ideally looking for
is infinite so if you try to estimate an
infinite function you will do a bigger
error
for sure and that's why i said you
should
all right but still
the thing is that the estimation problem
is maybe a bit harder
but a bit easier because because you
increase the action gap
uh you can afford more error but the
good thing is that you will have this
compensation of errors
so as long as you don't try to estimate
the onboard quantity
you will have a compensation which is
possible
and you can write uh if if
you have a tabular representation a
generative model it's quite easy to
write a bounce
uh his marginal setting is other because
uh what your average is a random error
of the world function
and what you will control when you do
statistical learning theory
is the average error according to some
norm of one iteration
so you cannot say much about how this
quantity will be half
but you know that sometimes you will
overestimate sometimes you will
underestimate and in average
you will have to more violence
yeah right so i understand that before
you basically like had to
fit two objects like a policy and a
value function
now you don't have to like have to deal
with these approximation errors in terms
of the policy but now you have to
estimate these log terms or these
k divergences in terms of a square two
norm right
which may not be like a very natural
way to measure errors in the policy
space
uh you don't have to you you have no
longer error since the policy space
yeah right yeah because you push that
into the queue functions
right but you still have yes
if i can jump in i think maybe you're
you're
on discomfort is maybe coming from the
looking at a single action right the log
policy of a single action
the kl itself might be a little better
behaved and maybe
that's like i'm assuming the analysis is
done with the kl divergence and not the
sample based log terms
you might take questions you should be
cautious about
numerical stability when you do log of
soft marks of these kind of things
but roughly the log policy is an
advantage
is an action gap yeah that's right so
it's well behaved and i can tell you
what should be the maximum range of the
action gap according to the original
problem
if if the action gap is delta in the
original problem it would be a delta
over one minus alpha
so if you take alpha 2.9 you have a time
20
it's still okay and but the thing is
that
this paper is really about this
protection if you go to continuous
action
if you fit a gaussian policy and you're
far from the mean
with a small variance you will have
clear problems but
this all the arguments all the
experiments we did uh
tutorials certifications all
in the case of disprotections right okay
well thank you okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
let others ask questions as well
we had a question from nan or a comment
from none about
linear horizon dependence and emir
mastered also wants to ask a question
should i start or go ahead okay great
so i enjoyed i mean the idea is very
cool and nice so uh
i kind of have a kind of speculative
question like it is
uh from the first step or one of the
first step was
adding this log of fighter and so you
interpret it as
some form of uh like additional reward
so what i was thinking is that what if
you just define another mdp
with that reward or another agent that
only receives that log
high term and not the original reward
and just train it
and consider that log high of another
agent as its reward so what would happen
i mean have you thought about it is it
something meaningful at all or it's it's
just random
this is something we have uh roughly
tried but for different reasons
um the thing is that uh you have a
coupling
between uh the policy term of the rod
it's not like having
two different rewards because uh
the aurora depends on the policy that
depends on the function that depends on
the world
so so you have this kind of coupling and
we thought about
uh separating the two terms but for a
different reason the reason is that
uh when when you do uh things like atari
as a scalar forward is important so in
atari
you have to keep the robot between minus
one and plus one or you have to
use over clip of things to
handle this and here we had something so
we were thinking that adding this stuff
uh could arm uh the behavior of the
problem
which is not the case we don't clip uh
the additional term
or maybe we keep it for numerical reason
but
not not that much and we were thinking
about
you have a paper by a deep mind which is
called a agent 57
where they do superhuman performance on
all atari guns
and at some point they use exploration
with interesting robots and
they use separate networks to learn
to reward because they have different
skills and this is something
we thought would be useful in our case
but the fact that you have this coupling
between
uh the bonus and the q function
uh i mean it's hard because the function
you will learn in the other mtp would
depend on the first one
so you should underscore things so it's
not that straightforward but
it could be an interesting uh direction
for sure
thank you fantastic uh we'll take two
more questions
one for comment from none and then
there's also a question on the q a
and then we'll move on to peter after
that uh maybe i can
just say a little more related to my
comment so uh
you know i think i've also looked into
the linear horizon dependence recently
and you know uh
one thing i realized from literature is
that bruno schwerer and
his collaborators have this paper
telling you that if you do something
like api
but you output the non-stationary policy
you still you also get
uh linear horizon dependence and sorry i
missed the first part of this talk but i
think i read the paper and remember
you also have to keep around some of the
history
like functions from past iterations so
that makes me think that maybe
it's better to do a comparison to
non-stationary like
like the non-stationary version of
dequeuer or something
have you tried that i'm actually curious
to see whether
not stationary qn actually perform any
better than like station ridicula
so yes uh indeed i i know
well bruno i know where uh this work on
non-stationary policies
and and in this form they he
showed that if you do
value duration of policy iteration uh
the
dependency to square dependency through
zeros in this type
and we tried uh not in the context of
this work with predator
uh one or three so we try to
to write a non-stationary decline
and it doesn't work at all we didn't
manage to to make it work
and it was the student that i could
advise with bruno so
nice theoretical thing but not practical
one
but you have also something called a
psdp
policy search by dynamic programming uh
the paper is a bit old it does roughly
the same thing but
um or an infinite origin setting it's
it's quite close to
what bruno did and they had some
experiments
but it's basically you go back to
backward induction and if for this to
work you have to start from the end
and the thing also is that you don't
have this uh compensation
of errors and i think um the
thing that make it works is the
compensation of heroes because i'm a bit
lying in the sense that the next one i
with linear dependency is for alpha
equal to 1 and 5.1 it's not the thing
that you do when you do deep learning
and with alpha lower than one
let's see the conversation of course
great we're almost out of time but
matsuya would like to ask this question
uh
pose it to you um this is a question
from a young bashkar
saying uh so we could use the kale
divergence
uh you know as the term as you've done
here could we use a different
divergence between policies and would we
get similar results
for example the total variation
so no
and why the reason why is that
um at least for the analysis
for my understanding of the bond uh
and i did them so i think i understand
them well
the thing is that you don't use the cool
background of divergence what you use
is that you say uh as i said before when
you use a kubaclava divergence it's like
saying that your policy will be greedy
according to the softmax
of the sum of all pascal functions
and this is really what you use to prove
the bond
and that's why when you do error in the
greatest step
it's no longer the case you no longer
have
this equivalence between uh i put cool
background
regularization or i i am soft max
according to the sum of q function
and to have this property
it's linked to fan shell conjugate
you must have divergence which has some
properties and the properties are that
you should go
to infinite the gradient of the function
you're considering to go to infinite
uh on the border of the complex
and i don't know if something else then
the entropy does the job
regarding this and i don't think that
total
variation does it at least
all right fantastic answer material
thank you very much uh on this note
maybe we will move to peter thank you
again matthieu if i can